gay
Daisy I've been thinking and you know
thinking
it's see
they ask you
the way you go
just tell them where it is you've been
[Music]
Monday
I through to Friday
ah Shelvin days is one must be slit rice
tea
my mornings I said from these agents our
misery
[Music]
sit right there I notice a sharp cutoff
there I got a final way to tune this
music so it cuts off a little bit
differently but that's Kohli Garrett
agar at and that's Kohli Guerette with a
song called ode to Daisy and I'm gonna
thank Kohli for sending that in we get a
lot of music sent in and some of it is
is wonderful and some of it is sheer
[ __ ] and that is uh that's one of those
good ones right there from colega Rhett
and there will be the link to that on
the YouTube we'll put the link in on
this on the iTunes and SoundCloud you
can check it out but thanks Kohli what's
up it is when it's Thursdays Wednesday
night I'm taping this sucker for
Thursday this thing going to come out
March 8th and that's it and this is this
past Thursday thank you guys for being
with me thank you for turning me on it's
you know I'm hitting that moment I'm in
then I'm in the new studio and I'm
hitting that moment where you know
there's that there's that there's that
general excitement when something
happens and then you got that secondary
moment where you're where it already
happened and you're like ah now what you
know it's kind of like if you're making
love to a woman or something and you and
you throw out that bust you know and you
let your nuts burst out and you make
yourself out into the you know you make
more yourself out of your Weiner and if
you do that into a woman's body which is
natural if people are grossed out right
now then you need to get your you got a
that's something with you because you
can't be getting great if people talk
about you know ejaculation or ejack or
whatever you can't be getting grossed
out because that's how we got here you
know people want on everybody we all act
like we got here in some special you
know like somebody brought us over in
like a porcelain bowl and just handed us
to our mother or there were a couple of
angels came down on a ladder and you
know dropped us off in our grandparents
arms or into our father's arms nobody
wants to nobody
to look at the facts that we shot out of
a wiener you shot out you shot out of a
wiener okay you know you might have new
shoes today or you might you know I've
just got your hair done or whatever but
the facts are facts and you shot out of
a wiener and you know sometimes we don't
want to we don't want to realize that
you know since we put ourselves in such
a special you know special we're so this
and we're so that you know or I got new
lip gloss or you know I got a fresh
shirt on you know where I'm you know
I've just learned how to do you know
speak French or whatever well guess what
oh well because the truth is that we all
we all shot out of a wiener and and I'm
having that moment now it's like si if
you did you know going back to what I
was saying if you did you know if if you
were to you know ejaculate into a woman
or a man if that's something you're
trying to do if you're trying to get a
man pregnant and from what I've heard
from my gay buddies you can try forever
okay probably not gonna happen the odds
that a small baby nine months say
there's gonna crawl out of that man's
buttocks slim to none but I'm having
that moment now where it's after that
after the after the you know that moment
of you know bursting where I'm realizing
that oh now here I am and it's a great
moment here in the studio it's just like
you know more stuff it's just realizing
okay you know today I put up a new sign
you know for this past weekend and what
to keep up of the fighter and the kid
guys because this was their studio so
it's you know I'm just having that
moment after you know that moment after
I'm having that moment you don't hear
about that moment a lot in time you know
it's always Minh it out to the barn and
they met the baby in the desert but you
don't hear about the days after that
when they were just hiking out of the
desert whatever and one of the animals
probably died a couple mules died and
you know and they're starving there
to cook up mule and eating grilled mule
in the sand and it's probably miserable
trying to eat you know something and
have sand at blowing imagine getting
sand in your food so you know you never
hear you never hear about that moment
after you know you just hear about that
first moment that initial and that's
when I was having the last episode I was
that fire had that freaking you know I
had that I had that you know I had that
that scavenger hunt going on inside of
my blood where there were little
particles of excitement running through
my blood just looking for the next hit
the next clue and now I'm getting more
into this setting of reality where it's
like okay this is that this is the next
moment or I'm realizing okay now I'm in
this new studio now what what's next
what are we looking at and and it's
exciting but it's you know it's just a
little bit more of a level field you're
coming down off that high but I'm happy
to be here with you guys today thank you
for turning me on it is Wednesday March
8th and you have that moment if you've
already bursted into a lady or you know
where you've busted into a man and then
you have that it you know that moment of
just elation and then after that you
have that moment where you're just you
know you're there and either the
person's pregnant or they are just want
you to leave or you want to leave or
nobody wants anybody to leave and you're
in love but I'm having that second
moment and that's when I'm experiencing
now that second moment and that's a
unique one man that's a unique time and
that's what's going on here you know
what I was thinking is it's springtime
it's spring cleaning is coming you know
it is it's time for a change you know
it's time for a change and I was
thinking I was getting a coffee a little
bit ago and they got a lobby here they
got like a fancy you know kind of like a
a little bit more fancy Lobby and they
got other people walking around and I'm
like holy [ __ ] I'm I'm gonna be meeting
other people with this new studio that's
one of the gifts of it I'm gonna run
into other people in the hallway I met a
guy down the hall
he knows UFO people
people who believe that that there are
other beings out there like me you know
and he said look I'd love to get you a
guest that's a UFO person and I never
really talked to UFO person you know a
lot I'd love to tap it to delve into the
dome of somebody who's hopped up on
extraterrestrials you know or somebody
who lays in bed at night and really
their mind is that expanded to wondering
what it's like to be thinking that
there's an alien maybe a jillion miles
away also thinking wondering if we exist
and and so it's cool I'm gonna be
running and I'm be running into new
people you know and that's one of these
secondary moments that I'm that I'm
absorbing you know it's one of these
other you know these other things that's
coming along you know like it's like
somebody it's like if somebody knocks
you the [ __ ] out yeah you got that
initial moment where you got knocked the
[ __ ] out but then after that you have
other moments you have that moment where
like you realize if anybody gives a [ __ ]
that you got knocked out do people come
over and try to help you
does nobody help you you know do do
somebody pull up in a car but just look
down at you and then drive off you know
you have those other moments you wait
you get but you you come to you realize
do I have blood on my shirt you know do
I have you know
ejaculate in my pants dude I had this
guy in my town right every time he get
knocked out he'd come all over himself
and so people were always knocking him
out this boy Nick and people are always
knocking him out and I felt so bad
because here's the thing Nick you told
everybody if something like that if you
have that magical power where when
somebody knocks you out or you go
unconscious that you ejaculate you don't
tell everyone okay you keep that to
yourself but it's spring cleaning it is
Thursday March 8th probably when you're
listening to this and I'm feeling
fortunate to be here with you guys I'm
feeling fortunate to be here with you
guys in the new studio I just had chin
came over from the fighter and the kid
you know I'm - I got their producer
stopping in and he's giving me all of
that
I don't know if you know chin he is a
he's an Asian country musician and he go
by GART Brooke is his country name and
if you want to check him out get out
there and check him out and he's a
extremely talented man and you know and
one thing it's fun to watch is if you
have an Asian friend and they're playing
the guitar playing the piano watching
their hands move it's like watching a
real it's like watching a very small
octopus you know in a in like in a do
the hurdles if you ever watched like a
like an Asian guy play the piano their
fingers are so small it's almost they
kind of they have to grown a little bit
even when they move their finger up on a
key because it's so high a piano key is
very high for an Asian finger like for a
regular you know polish Nicaraguan I got
these you know I got these violent
dancers hanging off I'll get these
phalanges that just straight up got
violence in them you know they got they
I got these acrobatic phalanges
acrobatic and hard-working acrobatic
that's the Nicaraguan side and hard work
and that's the Polish side and and but
if for an Asian guy it's really it's
almost like his fingers have to jump you
know that much force to play the piano
and so watching a guy like gar Brooke
you know watching him play or any Asian
person with a very tiny hands I knew an
Asian guy one of his fingers seven
centimeters long and yeah I mean that's
that's that's it's almost astronomical
so you know to watch them do that in the
art and the ability it takes for them to
move around those little you know
there's you know this quick little pause
it's very very beautiful to watch and
should almost be an Olympic sport you
know watching you know watching Asian
people do things should be an Olympic
sport I think I mean you know just
because they have such a I don't know
they just have such a they're just such
unique humans to me you know
and look I'm coming from a guy's
perspective I grew up in the town we
didn't have that we have black and white
you know we had one one Mexican kid that
showed up in seventh grade and then
outside of that we had a couple of
people that you know we had a lot of
people that were mixed and you know all
kinds of you know just human typos
living around us and you know a lot of
Darrell acts too you know first wig I
ever was in my town and a lot of people
don't know that this boy Bryan's
saint-pierre and they put him into the
mentally handicapped class because they
hadn't ever you know they never seen
something like that they'd never seen a
white person that wanted to be black and
so I remember in school they put him in
mentally handicapped classes and so
you'd have like the third lunch because
a lot of the special kids you know God's
favorites
they ate lunch in the third lunch period
and so you would have these you know
you'd have kids coming in that were
afflicted and affected and and then
you'd have you know it will you know
people with Walker's and people wearing
you know the people with that kid with
the bubble wrap or whatever run his neck
he had that um they bought him a small
you know one of those inner tube floaty
tubes he would play in if you were like
a little kid they had that but they had
it around his neck because he would kind
of chew on his shoulders a little bit
this boy Wyatt and Wyatt would get over
there and chew on his shoulders you know
and some of the kids sometimes would put
little chocolates and [ __ ] on his
shoulders and he would eat him off his
own shoulders and so you had but then
you had Bryan's saint-pierre and he
would be just wearing a Washington
[ __ ] starter jacket or an apex you
know Charlotte Hornets pullover jacket
and just dribbling invisible basketballs
all day and just posting up mentally
handicapped kids in a lunch line you
know what you got on this dunk quiet
Blake you know he would just be doing
[ __ ] like that and it was uh you know we
just had some wild characters man with
some wild characters don't you know I'm
talking about but I asked on the last
episode who listens to this podcast and
I got a couple of colors I called in I'm
just gonna drop you a little bit of
audio right now from these beautiful
cats right here
word hold on here we go
[Music]
sorry man I don't know what happened
right there
Jesus Christ dude I hate this [ __ ]
alright here we go and we got a co it's
hot dogs in San Diego I'm out here
pulling the graveyard shift and I just
want to let you know I'm a regular dude
with a bit of an irregular job my
official title is the cremation operator
which means exactly what it sounds like
I cremate people ooh now that's a dark
heart I think right there if you out
there you know burning bodies and I've
never done that man I've never burned
anybody you know I I saw a dude run back
into a fire once I'm looking for
something and I think it was drugs and I
don't know what happened to him and I've
wondered you know if they're like a
plane crash or something you know what I
would eat if somebody was cooked up you
know because here's the thing plane
crash you survived the bodies are only
going to be cooked the meat only many
good for what three four hours outside
so if you're gonna eat something you got
to eat quick you know and that's when
the meat is cooked when you know
whatever you know I'm trying to get
carnivorous or cannibal as' but you get
after you got a snack you got to be you
know snacky Jackie you got to get over
there and jump down and I would have the
ribs probably on somebody
alright store a couple I'd take
everybody's [ __ ] ribs you know I
think the ribs out everybody up and at
least everybody in coach cuz you know
they can be probably harder workers
people over sit in coach class so
they're probably a little more meat on
their ribs nothing fake ass fatty ribs
up there you get up there first class
ribs I ain't eating that [ __ ] but you're
a creamy you're a cremator whoo tell me
more I just want to let you know check
in say congrats on in these studio I
love the show they could keep on living
on thank you man I am gonna keep on
living in a spring time and I'm you know
when springtime it is it you know that
is one thing that's kind of nice about
the year the way we got it built
you know things come along you got that
next you know you got that next moment
you got that second moment you know
maybe Christmas we didn't go the way you
wanted it to
you know maybe you wanted to have a
girlfriend or something and you know it
didn't really pan out
maybe you got a gift for your lady and
then she broke up with you you got a
gift for your man and he had been
treating you well maybe Christmas wasn't
the thing maybe New Year's you chose
something you got that next moment New
Year's came what do you want to do how
do you want to let get into your year do
you want you know did you feel a lot of
pressure to go out to the club you know
did you feel a lot of pressure to go to
the nightclub and watch a bunch of
jacked up dudes
you know you know put on put wearing
perfume a lot of these men are wearing
perfume and let's don't pretend that
they're not you know they got Persian
guys out there wearing [ __ ] holding
honeysuckle honey holding the
honeysuckles under their arms and and
you know you know tying little things of
baby's breath around their dick and
different type of flowers or you got you
know you you you but you had New Year's
did you want to do something in and go
to the club or do you want to stay home
do maybe do some read and relax watch
the little Dateline murder mystery which
a lady you know but you had that next
moment and then now we got other moments
popping up you know Groundhog's Day if
you celebrate that you know I got a lot
of friends that look at celebration on
the internet for granddaughters dedo do
you know check out some [ __ ] or Black
History Month you know I've been looking
at different pictures of black people on
the internet all month now I did in
February you know just going through
trying to at least be honorable you know
check out some new black friends I don't
I don't see a lot very much or different
people I didn't know you know if you
type in unique black people you could
see who pops up dude
right here ten little known black
history facts you right here let me see
inoculation was introduced to America by
a slave so right there slavery you know
they were doing [ __ ] inoculating you got
a disease guess what you know your boy
here who's a slave is gonna help you out
so the earliest recorded protest against
slavery was by the Quakers in six
eighty-eight you know there's a lot of
stuff going on you could see that on the
internet just googling unique black
people over of the 12.5 million Africans
shipped to the new world during the
transatlantic slave trade fewer than
three hundred and eighty eight thousand
arrived in the United States so let's
look at that let's look at some numbers
right there okay about a third you know
so about a third of slaves that were
shipped came to the US and first of all
you know cuz we take a lot of flack in
America especially being a white male
for slavery and I didn't do it you know
somebody somebody else did it you know
but it's like but just because I'm white
and still alive sometimes I feel like a
lot of that pressure out there and the
repercussions of it you know still
falling a lot of white dudes and you
know and there is a responsibility there
we got a you know you know you have to
you know you have to recognize that
other cultures haven't had it as easy as
our culture in America right but at the
same time how about we tracked down who
the [ __ ] was selling people to other
people you know we got ancestry.com but
it doesn't tell you know I think they're
hiding some of the facts I think we
should everybody spit into the envelope
spit into the mail or whatever and find
out who was out there buying slaves so
we can put it you know we can start to
figure out who owes who and we get
through some of this [ __ ] and the
British did a lot of that and I'm not
pointing fingers at the British but
every now and then British people when
everybody's getting angry
you could chime in and be like um you
know we're sorry
so that stuff just makes me hate it
sometimes ma'am but yeah so it's
springtime man so then you know you got
Black History Month and then the next
thing comes along and it's springtime
and then it's Easter and you got that
next moment you know you got that
secondary moment if something wasn't
going your way you got that secondary
moment but I appreciate you calling mr.
cremator and do that is I'm wondering
you got to be a sick
[ __ ] to be out there burning bodies
man you got to be a sick Rick to be out
there cooking locals daddy you know I'm
saying I don't even like to if
something's more than two minutes in the
microwave I don't bother with that [ __ ]
ain't doing that and you out there
freaking grilling up males and females
boy you know some next-level man I'd
love to know a little bit more about
that if you could hit the hotline
actually and let me know and this is
pretty sick but let me know a little bit
more about it let me know three
interesting facts that I wouldn't know
about cremation and now I'll put it on
next episode on the Monday episode we
have one more caller right here I want
to know who called in and I was just
talking about hey you know I'm out here
are you out here here we go
what up deal this is Richard from
Arizona he wanted to know who this
mysterious well I'm a mechanic aka
automotive technician grease monkey
anyway I shift up the compressor on my
ankle may or may not be broken but it
still mattress chip I care so keep it up
man thank you Richard the grease monkey
from over there in Arizona I think he
said and you're a mechanic you know I
never been super mechanical you know I
remember taking some [ __ ] apart one time
when I was kind of keyed up on a little
bit of dust one time but I don't know if
I put it back together you know that's
kind of where I met but I remember a
long time I had a Chevrolet I had a
blazer and that thing didn't uh the it
would overheat about every hour and a
half and it would all the water would
come out so I had to fill that did I had
about thirty gallons of water in that
thing
and I would just go out and just you
know every hour and a half you had to
pull over it was kind of sucks because
if you had a date you had to like kind
of make up excuses you know like I'm
just gonna look under the hood make sure
you know I used to tell chicks that you
know I don't know if had enough gasoline
in the car and I'd be like oh yeah my
gas tank is in the is in the front of
the car and so I'm like yeah I'm gonna
look under the hood and make sure I got
enough gas because my gauge doesn't work
inside and then I sneak that guy you
know I'd sneak that gallon out with me
get a gallon
you know and load that thing back up
because all that steam would have been
coming off but the scary part is you got
to get that hot they had that hot cat
and boy everybody knows if you had a dad
with a piece-of-shit car that you know
my daddy drove that Delta 88 Nana and a
and a cutlass and you knew if you had
that [ __ ] you had to get that hot cat
boy that's when it got dangerous my dad
I remember a couple times made me take
my shirt off so he could have something
to put in his hand and get that hot cap
off and that thing boy I was 50-50
chance if he was gonna lose a [ __ ]
limb every time you know an Asian person
probably have used two hands on that hot
cap can you even imagine a beautiful
asian person just taking off that hot
cap boiling that radiator oh man
beautiful thoughts out there but ya see
but I remember that man I remember
having to run around with all that extra
water I remember one time I bought a
bunch of [ __ ] sparkling water on
accident or you know water that had you
know but dazzling it and that [ __ ] was
running up and I was just you know I was
running on [ __ ] Perrier rolling
around town Gang Gang boy that's about
as French as you can get
putting Perrier in your radiator but
yeah did I remember that those were some
fun times man now all these cars it's
like you don't really get to work on
them as much you know the new cars
because everything's all electronic and
everything's all you know under all
these safety guards and [ __ ] like that
the old cars that [ __ ] fanbelt was
running too you could [ __ ] you could
lose a cousin into that [ __ ]
dude if you had a long-haired cousin
somebody listening a little bit of ZZ
Top you know or somebody that listen a
little bit of Skynyrd and they got too
close to that fan belt that first it
would permit and then it would permit
whole [ __ ] body just pull them right
into that thing but yeah man I
appreciate you calling and I appreciate
listen to the podcast I just want to
know who listens I want to who I'm
talking to
and who's out there spending time with
me and thank you Richard the grease
monkey for being here and thank you
mister cremator
for being out there you know it's nice
to know that when I was fixing cars when
y'all was out there you know getting rid
of people's loved ones and that's the
dark arts man but we're here man you
know we're going to shoot I'm shooting
project you don't get this great project
up and shooting right now at Comedy
Central I'm feeling so fortunate you
know because I've been out here working
what 14 years doing this comedy and and
I'm feeling fortunate because they got
uh we doing this thing we doing this pot
is based on the podcast people called in
you know looking for suggestions or
whatever and uh and now we're do
shooting these little episodes for
Comedy Central and we're gonna put some
of them out and trying to keep it as
real and as you know just just as 100 as
possible and it's been a blast man and I
got to watch one of the cuts today and
this [ __ ] was I thought it was pretty
funny so I'm excited to share that with
you guys when it comes out soon I don't
know when that'll be
and then we're going to my neighborhood
my old hood man
because I'll some monkeys got out when I
was young
you know when I grew up in the [ __ ]
and I grew up over on McGhee Street down
there in Covington Louisiana off Ali
Road and Lee Road had a bunch of dead
man's curves I mean this [ __ ] that Road
had nine dead man's curves on it and by
the end of the road nobody was even
there were no homes cuz nobody [ __ ]
made it that far and uh and they had um
they had you know just it was just kind
of a [ __ ] you know playing football
on the street you know getting beat up
by big kids or when you were young a fat
kid was big to remember that you're like
damn that kid's big music no no he's
just really fat you know but he could
still whoop your ass and I remember
getting beat up a decent amount you know
here and there and um and I just
remember more fun back then you notice
were more fun back then I remember they
had this do mr. Doug Brown on the
weekend sometimes his wife was you know
she was kind of wild you know and she
kind of will put on this kind of I don't
wanna say lingerie type [ __ ] but it was
pretty you know it would show at least
some knees you see both knees at the
same time and for a young kid bro when
you're like 11 or 12 that'll get you
hard and we go over there dude fifty
cents a dollar bro
get six or eight of us together his wife
would [ __ ] bust aspera his wife at
fart in the living room and let us all
sit there and listen man four six eight
bucks and you can't you know nowadays
here's the crazy part nowadays you do
that
that's a crime somebody's gonna you're a
pervert or you're a you're not a good
person
you know but we go over there for mr.
Doug's lady she bust ass six or eight
bucks on the weekend get a group of us
ten of us sit in the living room you
know and once she hit that real heater
coming out of her we'd all run out and
that was it that was our hole and we
would laugh but we would laugh for the
next three days about that just
reenacting it you know she kind of had
um she had that little body where
everything is kind of connected a little
bit we're like the butt cheeks connected
to the neck muscle you know so when she
turned that when she will walk her whole
body would kind of grind you know just
like she was almost like she uh you ever
seen one of those things that oh if you
put a rock in it it'll polish it and you
run that little motor and it just spins
and it just you know those little things
go and it just polished as a rock
her body was like that you know her ba
[ __ ] hole where like her shoulders like
with each hip when when one hip would
come up the the show the other shoulder
would go up when she will walk you know
almost like a uh like she was churning
you know like you could put a piece of
sand in a vagina and come back you know
six years later and she drop out of
Pearl you know what I'm saying she had
that body she had that body karate going
on and um and I think because she was
like that her body was so active I mean
she could almost you know I don't want
to say you know fart on command cuz this
is kind of vulgar but she could do it
she had that skill you know she had that
novice rural skill set and we go over
there and it was six or eight bucks you
know we'd spend it and that was and that
was it you know I just missed some of
those days man you know I just miss I
think what I miss about being young
not only know how we got on this but but
I don't [ __ ] ever know how we got on
anything what I miss was just that
anything could happen you know I missed
that sense that anything could happen
like anything you could ride down she
could get in a fight you know you can
find something in a ditch she thought it
was treasure you got home your mom's
like this is a [ __ ] this is part of a
hubcap and she would beat you ass
you know just anything was pop anything
could happen you know there was just a
world of possibility out there you can
you got to sneak out of the house that
was always the funnest wasn't a sneaking
out of the house just you just anything
was possible when you got out of the
house at night and you weren't supposed
to be the fact that you because your
parents not only are they your parents
they're like they're also like the
police and they're also like the the
provider and they're also like the the
extension cord you know there are all
these things and when you started to get
away from that and you know have your
own moments everything was just so alive
it was so alive when you were young and
I'm not trying to be a debbie downer
something like that way you know I think
when we're older we got to find that we
got to go looking for that we got to go
looking for that bit you know for that
next moment you know we got to go you
know we got to go looking for that next
moment you know I keep coming back to
this kind of second moment thing you
know from all different sides but yeah
now now if you want that I'm realizing
now because for for many years of my
life I've felt like I don't man I was
bored I'm bored you know I felt like I
don't do you know this don't feel
inspired and I'm sure some of you guys
feel like that and what I've learned for
me is that I got a do stuff to get
inspired you know I was talking to Joe
Rogan a couple of months ago and I'm you
know I'm name-dropping here because I
mean I'll name dropped that man's name
any time you know he's one of a kind I
mean he really is one of a kind like
there's some people you meet him you're
like oh this haven't met this before and
that's Joe Rogan
and uh and he goes man you gotta go do
stuff that's what he told me you got to
go do stuff you can't just be waiting
for life you got to go do stuff and I
find that when you make changes and you
do something different now we're gonna
try something else
you don't like camping go camping you
know yesterday I was so tired I got home
I didn't the last thing I wanted to do
was go for a run but I just went for it
I said you know what I'm gonna try
something different and then when I got
home I felt better I felt I don't know I
you know I cleaned up around the place a
little bit and you know I made myself
some food instead of just just ordering
some [ __ ]
you know we're eating the [ __ ] some
time out getting the in in the fridge
and eat seven or eight pieces of cheese
and call that dinner but setting dinner
that's a bunch of cheese is what that is
you know so you know I'm just trying to
be inspired and I'm trying to like I'm
realizing that if I want to get inspired
and I want to feel not bored that I got
to make that next moment you know I got
to make that next moment now you know I
got I got a I got a I got to create
something that is gonna then provide me
you know I got it I got to make change I
got to make change you know I get so
comfortable I don't want to change you
know I don't want to get into a into a
you know deep I give you know a my I
want to get into a deep relationship
because I don't I don't want to grow up
you know I don't want to you know I
think somewhere inside of me I don't
want to fall in love because I don't
want to you know have to get married and
have a faint you know I don't want you
know why I don't want things to be any
different because I'm safe where I am
I'm comfortable right here but then at
the same time I'll sit there and think
to myself man nothing's changing you
know I'm not even getting this I'm not
getting that second moment because I'm
not getting that first moment and that
was one thing even just about getting a
studio it was like hey you know
did this shot now I have never in my
life made a choice that said man it's
gonna put my back it's gonna put my bank
at zero to get into this thing but I'm
like why [ __ ] I've never done that so
I'm gonna try to do something ballsy you
know and that's something that you know
it came from and that came from Adam
Carolla listen these podcasts he says
you could be I don't know it's not penny
wise don't be penny you know don't think
in pennies think in dollars or something
like that it's like you know don't pinch
pennies make dollar something I don't
[ __ ] know what it is but what he's
saying is if you're always worrying
about the penny you gonna you're gonna
miss out on the dollar and that was the
thing it was like I'll take a chance
I'll get into this new studio and see
what's next
and um and yeah it's just I don't know
man there's a lot of this I guess I
gotta just you know I'm in that space
where I just you know a lot of new stuff
going on you know what I'm thinking
about I don't know I guess part of me is
thinking about like well you know is
this podcast gets bigger like if you
know you know you know do I count you
know what can I do to just keep being me
you know to not feel you know a lot not
let my ego get up and to not feel you
know and to not get disconnected from
Who I am
because sometimes it's not even that you
grow it's that you forget and there's a
difference you know like I want to grow
and I want to have more of a breath of
the of I would have more ability to
affect change but I don't want to forget
you know I don't want to forget you know
where I am from or Who I am you know and
I don't want to forget to share how I
feel you know and sometimes I feel I do
feel like that this pocket
sometimes has gotten away from that a
little bit over the past few months it's
just you know being afraid to share not
afraid to share how I feel but just so
caught up in my everyday moments and
being busy that I don't even know how I
feel you know it's another sometimes
that's the truth sometimes I just get
going so much I don't even know how I
feel and that's kind of scary man and I
think he you know you just got a system
that was just slow it down
and I know I'm talking about a lot of
stuff here and sorry I you know I'm just
I'm a little all over the place it's a
lot going on there's a lot going on you
know what I mean I honestly I don't even
know if I wanted to just to do tonight
because I didn't like had anything to
talk about
but you know now I'm sitting here
thinking and you know I'm grateful that
I did so appreciate you guys being here
with me and uh just helped me be here
you know help me be here yeah literally
helping me be here in this moment I got
a text that came in to the hotline the
hotline is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three if you a young man
s struggling or an older man that
struggling with something you know you
got something on your mind or someone
your heart and you need some help
something you're thinking about
something that when you wake up it's in
your brain you know and it doesn't have
to be that they maybe you're not even
upset that about maybe you're not even
confused about the problem maybe you're
just confused why is this in my brain
all the time but hit the hotline you
know let us know what's going on and and
if I can offer some suggestions I'll try
and help you you know cuz I look I don't
have I don't have a ton of knowledge but
I'll be damned if I haven't made some of
the poorest choices in life and been
through a lot of [ __ ] man you know and
some of its been good and some of it's
been and some of its been bad you know
but it put me right here where I am
today
and and hopefully one day you know I
know we're a fact we're doing some good
stuff dude we've had some coolest people
call in and people sharing things I got
this text that came in the text was
what's up dude Matt from New York
then running through this past weekend's
every day pretty much I've been going
backward from newest to oldest and was
listening to a show over the summer
where you said you were gonna cover the
topic of a day of addiction on the next
podcast the next the next podcast came
and you didn't really talk about it I
would love to hear your thoughts on that
anyway keep it up and the podcast is
hilarious and one of the best out there
Gang Gang thanks Matt for for tuning in
and for checking it out
yeah may you know you know I'd never
thought that I struggled with addiction
you know I never thought that I did and
then I found myself did I found myself
high on cocaine driving a taxicab in New
York City and the thing was that I
didn't drive taxis I don't even own a
taxi the driver was in the backseat with
an escort that he had bought from me
that I didn't want and we were [ __ ]
living it up dude you know and and I
realized that I just don't react well
with some drugs and that drug for me was
cocaine man that shit's fun as [ __ ] dude
what did they put what's cocaine made
out of fun because that [ __ ] was fun man
I had a good time and I hadn't even been
doing cocaine long I just started doing
it I had just started doing it but you
know and that morning that same morning
I ended up on the radio show Opie and
Anthony or Opie and Jim Norton
yeah Opie and Jim Norton this is two
years ago and Darryl Strawberry was the
other guest on the radio and Here I am
looking at a man who's baseball cards I
collected growing up and I couldn't even
talk I couldn't even talk that's how
high I was I couldn't even speak and I
just fell I don't know I just and Darryl
Strawberry was eloquent successful well
put together you know he was all he was
all he was my dreams he was you know he
was things that I guess I always you
know I guess somewhere in my heart I
wanted to be and and I was like damn I
and I got back to LA and somebody
seeing what was going on and I just told
him I told him that story man I told him
look dude I've had a great couple of
days but I can ended up at a radio
station and I couldn't even talk
couldn't even think
man couldn't feel my face then I
couldn't feel my face the highest I
could feel was my neck running on neck
thoughts and and you can't think out of
your neck because your neck don't have
any ideas in it it's very primal ideas
very primitive you're running on that
limbic system you're running on the base
year of you know the top of your spine
the base of your brain basic instincts
and there's a picture you can go out
there and look at it if you google Opie
and Jim Norton Theo von Darryl
Strawberry there's a picture of us all
after that show and I'm on the side just
geeked out of my brain and it was just
embarrassing man and and look nobody
even knew nobody knew at the episode but
I knew and I'd had a wild night and I
knew and I knew I was like man I uh and
then after that I got back to LA and I
told her friend about it and next thing
you know they started talking to me
about addiction and you know they took
me to a meeting an a a meeting I saw you
know I go to that [ __ ] you know now and
I say [ __ ] I don't mean it like that you
know I'm being like you know you know
and well I'll always be in there I don't
know okay I'm not saying it like that
you know but I just know for now it
helps me that since I went into this
since I went in there nothing in my life
has gotten worse not one thing and uh
and here's the thing for me I find that
I don't even the things because my
problem was even really my problem was
not even really drugged an alcohol my
problem was I didn't know how I didn't
know how to feel you know something
happened to me or something you know
when I was young I got so just was so
disconnected as a child that I didn't
know I didn't have any real feelings
except for just pain and discomfort man
I was just always juggling these same
couple shitty feelings and the only time
I could even feel joy was when I was you
know doing humor
or being humorous and that's why I
really fell in love with humor because I
needed that because I needed to actually
laugh I needed to be shaking and having
a sound come out of my mouth that's what
happens when you laugh your body shakes
and you have a sound that comes out of
you
I needed that much to feel anything good
otherwise I wasn't feeling good jack
I wasn't feeling good and so that's what
I've you know and and and since I've
gotten in he gone in you know and dealt
with it and gotten into some of that
stuff you know those old feelings have
gone to win I got new feelings creeping
in and look I've done some other
therapies and going some other stuff and
we'll get in all that man you know we
got a lot of time to go on this podcast
not today but in the future but it's uh
you know it's that that programs helped
me learn how to deal with my emotions
that's what it's helped me for it's like
emotional summer camp and the truth is
sometimes I sit in those a rooms and I
listen to people share stories and and
they're the best stories man I love
listening to people's stories I love the
trial of the reality I want to know what
makes you feel man I want to know what
makes you feel because I want to know
what makes me feel and most of my life
growing up I didn't know you know I
didn't know what I felt and I didn't
know I just didn't know I just didn't
know and I was ashamed of myself and I
was embarrassed and I didn't fight he's
I was I just was and I thought the world
hated me in the world didn't hate me you
know the world didn't hate me
and um and these are things that I
slowly am starting to figure out and
learn and uh but I'll be in those rooms
and I'll hear people share stories and
everybody's laugh and Brian did I was in
a meeting yesterday in the morning at
7:00 a.m. some dudes sharing a story but
how [ __ ] up he was and he had all
these hookers living at his house and
all this and one of them's people
overdose and I said in every room is
laughing it's and it was a hilarious
story
and I realize sitting in there with all
these people laughing and it's all this
was a men's meeting man it's not him
this wasn't a homoerotic thing this was
just men you could be straight or gay
but it was men in there and I realized
that all I ever really wanted was to be
in a group of men having fun and not
feeling scared or intimidated you know
I'm not feeling less than but cuz that's
how I would feel man growing up a group
and a lot of fear you know a lot of you
know people fighting you know go outside
always getting attacked by dogs got
attacked by two cats on my birthday one
of them came off the roof at me this
[ __ ] [ __ ] ginger and so you know I
just wanted a feel man and I sit in
those rooms and I'm in there and there's
a bunch of men and everybody's laughing
together and having fun and I realized
man this is this is just what I always
wanted this is the same thing I go out
looking for if I were if I went to a bar
ever beer if I went to party I just
wanted this I just wanted to be around a
group of guys you know or chicks it can
be women too I go to all you know
different types of them and I just
wanted to be in a group of people and
feel okay and that's the first time in
my life that I ever really felt that was
in some of those AAA meetings but we'll
talk about more about that stuff in the
future man the addiction stuff you know
and but I appreciate you texting it
about it man and I'm sorry that I didn't
know that I said that I would do that
and I didn't and I appreciate you
holding me to it you know I got a ton of
stories about that's too kind of [ __ ]
and uh did I want one time in college
man I got so high Brock because they had
some weed going around sometimes it
wasn't weed it was other [ __ ] you know
you don't know what's in there you know
somebody sprang a little bit of [ __ ]
you know Daniels dirty dandruff up in
that joint and next thing you know you
[ __ ] polishing your furniture with
your tongue you know people getting
gripped up and and I remember you don't
have a so high dude I had to call the
police but there was a party going on
outside right so I called the cops on
myself man I was like I'm
[ __ ] up need y'all come get me so
these ambulances show up and [ __ ]
everybody I kid and the ambulances are
like you know they're like looking
what's going on you know everybody the
party's like what the [ __ ] some dudes
coming into this house
and I went out to the ambulance and got
into the passenger seat and they're like
what the [ __ ] and the drive the EMT
comes over is like what's going on
what's like hey man it's me I called
let's roll dude because I just didn't
want to be embarrassed I was so
embarrassed how a lot of people would
think that I called this Ambo and just
got in the passenger seat and then they
took him to the hospital dude and I
don't know if I'm the only patient ever
to ride to the hospital in a passenger
seat of an ambulance bruh but if I am
son gang gang boy made the most out of
that second moment bro because that
first moment that [ __ ] was crooked when
those dudes showed up and there's an
ambulance and it's party because the
last thing you want to do do when you're
young honestly is [ __ ] die in front
of your buddies because it's gonna be
sad for everyone and it's gonna be
embarrassing his [ __ ] you know or get
hurt like severe you know you just don't
want to do deal with that it's because
for me anyway I'm worried about enough
about what people were thinking at that
time if I don't have any positive any
positive thoughts from about myself so
if I don't have any positive thoughts
about myself the only place I can get
positive thoughts from or other people
so if I don't think good about myself I
need them to think good about me because
that's the only way there's gonna be
good thinking about me if that makes any
sense I was super worried about
everybody thought so so man in dudes the
man buzz came in them cats rolled in and
I was like [ __ ] this can be embarrassing
as [ __ ] dude
I just put gel in my hair before I even
smoke that weed so you can't be going
out all your hair's all [ __ ] slicked
up and you're going out on a stretcher
Brown dough um-um-um plants bro no so I
just strolled out there boy like a G
dude and got him in the [ __ ]
passenger seat of that Ambo as if they
were picking me up you know as if I just
got the [ __ ] emergency
uber you know Gang Gang boy fire up that
fire up the that IV drip baby and let's
ride out fire up that IV drip
so yeah man I got to tell you this man
that this past weekend is brought to you
by zip recruiter zip recruiter every
business needs great people and a better
way to find them
well something better than posting your
job online and just praying for the
right people to see it that's not gonna
work cat daddy that doesn't work that's
old-fashioned we're gonna do put up a
wanted poster that's ineffective no you
got to go mainstream you got to go main
male and that's where zip recruiter
comes in to help zip recruiter knew
there was a smarter way so they built a
platform that finds the right job
candidates for you not for other people
for you zip recruiter learns what you're
looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job in fact 80% of employers who
post a job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day the right candidates are
out there and zip recruiter is how you
find them imagine knowing a ninja well
now you do that ninja is zip recruiter
so use that cat-daddy to find the
quality candidate you need right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
that's right free just go to zip
recruiter comm slash tpw that's zip
recruiter comm slash t pw it's the
smartest way to hire that says zip
recruiter right there beyond thinking
now man now I'm feeling more inspired
honestly dude I just felt inspired you
know just felt honestly just that warm
moment that everything was going to be
okay and you know when I started this
episode today I was feeling you know a
little bit more unsure to be honest with
you and I'm gonna try to get more honest
with you guys man sometimes I fall off a
little bit but I want this to be a hovel
for honesty bro real [ __ ]
speaking of hovels do that that that
word was just in this was just in this
in this right up here and so I want to I
want to play this call that came in
right here from Logan here we go hey
what's up Theo this is Logan calling
from Sacramento
who's Sacramento that's the home of
missing people and I've said that before
but everybody in Sacramento looks like
they could be a missing person if you've
ever noticed that let's hear more things
for Colin Logan hey so I've been
thinking about this topic for a little
while now and what it has to do is with
some experiences that I had in my
childhood my friends and I would
consistently come across I guess what we
would call like either like bum huts or
like a pervert Hubbell and what I mean
by that is there would be places where I
think that you know maybe homeless
people or maybe teenagers would maybe
congregate too you know apparently
collect and look at pornography and you
know oftentimes we would find like you
know discarded clothing in there oh I
definitely remember those that was the
funnest when you found that in the woods
you thought it was like a cool camp next
thing you know you're in there they got
a couple they got a playboy you know
they got a maybe some pictures of crotch
or some you know somebody made took a
bunch of pictures of titties and balled
them all up into a ball
you found a titty ball I remember that
man you find like dude I remember one
time somebody had hung AE Guana okay an
iguana up by two pieces of yarn right
she had an iguana hanging off the inside
of this it was like a little shack that
was in the woods it was always I guess a
homeless person had lived in there
somebody down on their luck and the
Iguana liked it it did like kind of just
become like mortified or something and
you know probably something that the
crematorium guy would you know want to
grill up but it'll become more to you
know just kind of petrified a little bit
and you just had this dude I remembers
getting into that hovel that little
shack just like looking around a [ __ ]
and then turning and that iguana was
right there hanging in the air because
you don't expect to see a Guana in air
no iguana is a land creature
or branch creature and just to it just
see one midair man it felt like a ghost
just sucked my dick bro it felt it was
tough man it was a tough moment but I do
remember this pervert hubble's dude I
remember going into one one time they
had to empty things a yogurt us and then
a spoon in a can of Vaseline so like
some dude you know have been geeked up
on that freaking Soul skeet you know
that magic freaking uh methi Murg
and he had I guess probably eaten half a
thing of uh a Vaseline so I mean I guess
that's one way to do it but we imagine
the [ __ ] you would take after that
imagine that I mean just that thing
would jump out of your ass like a
[ __ ] happy dolphin bruh you wouldn't
dude you wouldn't be able to wear pants
probably for a couple days dude the
turbid slip out of your ass like a
burglar with a radio that thing is gone
brother beautiful man but we'll listen a
little more Logan what do you what else
you got to say about them hovels bro err
blood times empty liquor black liquor
bottles kind of like off-brand liquor
you know like like plastic bottle like
tequila
another time in the center of a golf
course stand of bushes in a golf course
there was like a small little tunnel
little passageway that led into an
opening in the center of these bushes
where there was you know a lot of
different pornography and like again
like discarded clothing and editor yeah
yeah man I know what you're talking
about yeah pervert hovels yeah they had
them you know like I was homeless dude
or a perv or some man that you know
couldn't you know his wife wouldn't let
him jerk off in the house and he had a
you know build a little shelter out in
the woods and jerk off out there yeah
man that was exciting stuff you know
that was exciting stuff they used have a
dude by us who this guy was a guest kind
of a pedophile I guess well we didn't
know it we thought he was just a dude
that would get into holes in the in the
ground and he would dig these holes
right and he would dig these holes and
he'd go stand in them so you would see
like
you know he'd dig about a 4-foot hole so
it would be up to his nipples really
he'd be standing in this deep kind of
holy a dug and and you wouldn't know
kind of what was going on and then if
you got close over there that one time
my buddy got closer over there and the
dude was jerking off so this whole time
we thought this dude just been kind of
like a you know kind of a bootleg
paleontologist or somebody that you know
just doesn't feel comfortable standing
on the you know Flat Earth and or you
know standing at sea level or whatever
he wants to get a little lower and then
lo and behold this dude you know cuz
sometimes you'd be like 20 feet away
from it's just standing you know with
his you know torso and his head out of a
hole with his arms just resting on the
ground sometimes you have his arms in
arms in the hole with him as well and
this dude's [ __ ] skeet now this
dude's doing self skeet out there just
dark art and end of the freaking you
know into the worm walls of this hole so
I don't know man I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on out there
oh but yeah yeah crazy times growing up
man crazy times and finding those
pervert hovels I do remember those
homeless hobbles I do remember those
what else man what else is going on let
me hit another level right here we got
another call that came in here we go hey
Theo this is Jordan up in Calgary
Alberta hey Jordan nice to see you man
audibly because that's what the only way
I can see right here is audibly through
this call and I'll say this to you
Jordan that I will be in Calgary and
that's June 15th and 16th at Yuk Yuk's
comedy club up there in Alberta also
April 20th and 21st I'll be in Hasbrouck
Heights Jersey at bananas April 6th and
7th I'll be at Tampa Florida at Rock
Brothers brewing Oxnard March 23rd of
that weekend has been canceled they had
to move my dates and then I'll be in
Spokane and Tacoma March 15th through
17th you can check those out but let's
hear let's hear more from your brother
here we go
so about eight months ago my younger
brother who's 29 he passed away from a
seizure oh man I'm so sorry to hear that
Jordan thank you for calling us sharing
this sharing it with us man only hear
more it was very hard you know
I was very heartbroken the family is
having a hard time recovering so like
about eight months ago I flew home went
to the funeral and a lot of people were
asking me if I was coming home soon
because I've been out west for about 10
years you know good oK you've been out
in the West I'm guessing so it's
Vancouver or something and you went to
home to the funeral and people were
asking if you were coming home let's
hear more good job good lifestyle good
quality of life lots going on so it's
kind of reluctant to say yeah I will be
moving back so I promised my parents
asked me to move on them so I'm just
curious men you know there's more of a
quality life in a big city but at the
end of the day families what important
and it is a heck of a lot cheaper to
live back than the East Coast I'm kind
of stuck here man I was hoping you know
you can you can weigh in on this brother
man I think it's sweet at the end that
you called me brother there at the end
man you know I'm so sorry man I'm so
sorry for your loss you know I don't
know what you guys's relationship was
because relationship can have a lot to
do with losing a sibling you know there
were times in my life where I could have
cared less I think if some of my family
members passed away honestly you know I
don't think I've ever admitted that
before but just because I didn't have a
connection to him you know but now you
know now if I lost my brother you know
just I mean it would just break my heart
and so I really you know I don't know if
it's empathize or sympathize but I can
you know I can and if you guys had a
good connection man then I can only
imagine you know what that's been like
and have to go home and and you know see
your family and you know it sounds like
it this is this is on your mind and it's
on your heart you know you kind of had
some you had a couple answers yourself
there you know you know said the quality
of life isn't better where you are but
you have family back there I think you
have two responsibilities one to
take care of yourself because if you're
not in a good space then you're not
going to be able to help anybody or be
there for anyone and if you do move home
then it's you know it's anything in a
matter if you're not healthy and to to
take care of your family and I think you
if you do things in that order then
everything will work out you know just
try not to mix them you know if you're
unsure ask yourself you know is this
something I'm doing for me or is this
something that I'm doing for them and
sometimes something you're doing for
them will be something that you want to
do for you and and I think that that uh
that you'll figure it out that you'll
figure it out okay but definitely know
that you're not alone in in thinking
about your brother and if you get
confused it would trust your instincts
you know what does your heart tell you
you'll know you sound like a loving dude
but honestly and you'll know when you
know you'll know if you've been home
long enough or if you haven't been there
enough just trust your heart you know
trust your heart and trust your
instincts I think when something really
real happens like that in our lives the
thing that we can probably trust the
most that's when you don't think with
your brain as much and you think with
your heart you know you let your heart
guide you when things are really real
you let your heart you let your heart
guide you and your heart I don't think
it'll steal you wrong steer you wrong
I'm sorry but I I'll be thinking about
my brother and I'm gonna text him or
call him as soon as we get done and just
let him know that I love him I got to
tell you guys man star flow is the
location for fans trying to link up and
get closer to their favorite celebrities
star flow is a safer ecosystem where
your information won't be sold on the
black market it provides a hub for
consumers to access their favorite
talents and celebrities and exclusive
content in seconds all right we're
talking about getting a lot closer to
your favorite stars and getting content
that no one else can it's available on
the App
store or at star flow comm star flow is
reshaping the influencer economy by
providing an infrastructure network
enabling an ecosystem where individuals
can thrive and where everybody can
interact and participate in the creation
and consumption of value that star flow
dot-com you guys check it out I I'm
gonna jump off the line man if you guys
have a thought on anything that popped
into this week's episode you know you
know if I don't know anything that
resonated with you hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three check out the studio on YouTube
make sure to subscribe we're almost at
30,000 subscribers at 30,000 I'm gonna
unleash a new a new clip so a stand up
clip so some new stand-up I'll put up
there on the YouTube that you guys
haven't seen before we talked about some
neat stuff today I appreciate you guys
being here for me
I appreciate you turning me on on the
way out since everybody loved us so much
we're gonna listen to a little bit of
Stevie starlights
[Music]
and I'll put this link in as well
estimation nation
see the wall
[Music]
[Applause]
slip some way
[Music]
and that's Stevie starlight we're gonna
have him in studio one day we are close
to getting this we're close to getting
this this this studio capable to have a
guest so we're close I want to thank
everyone on patreon for all your support
if you haven't checked out patreon
recently I put up that um I put up the
video of going to visit the smallest
horse in the world cuz I visited the
smallest horse in the world and that's
Tom Thumb oh excuse me beautiful animal
alright guys as always this episode
brought to you by grey block pizza and
you could check him out 18:11 Pico
Boulevard and way to the beach go to
grey block get that hitter you know that
daddy's back you're back we're here I'll
see you guys on Monday